FIRE.
THAT'S HOW SERIOUS THIS IS.
ACCORDING TO NANCY PELOSI.
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY IS A
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTING THE
STATE OF LOUISIANA.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE MARKED FOR
ALL TIME.
THIS IS INDELIBLE, THIS MARK OF
IMPEACHMENT, THE MARK OF THE
BEAST.
WHAT'S YOUR ASSESSMENT OF THAT
CLAIM?
>> WELL I THINK THE SENATE WILL
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THI
THIS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE MENSA
MATERIAL, TUCKER, TO SEE THAT
SPEAK SPEAKER PELOSI IS SWOLLEN
WITH PARTISAN RAGE.
THE WHOLE PROCESS IN THE HOUSE
WAS RIGGED.
WE ARE GOING TO DO IT
DIFFERENTLY IN THE SENATE, WE
WILL TREAT BOTH SIDES FAIRLY.
AS I SAID THE OTHER DAY, WHEN WE
ARE DONE, I DON'T WANT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO LOOK AT THE
SENATE'S WORK AND SAY, WELL, WE
JUST GOT RUN OVER BY THE SAME
TRUCK TWICE.
IT WAS UNFAIR IN THE HOUSE AND
UNFAIR IN THE SENATE.
YOU SAY LOOK.
THE SENATE WAS FAIR.
THEY GAVE YOU TIME TO BOTH SIDES
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
ALLEGATIONS IN THE SENATE VOTED
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WILL TRY TO
DO.
>> Tucker: PROBABLY GOT NO
VOTE AT THIS STAGE BUT WHAT
WOULD YOU EXPECT THE TIMELINE
ROUGHLY TO BE?
>> THERE WILL BE A PRESENTATION
FIRST BY THE PROSECUTION.
COMMON SENSE WOULD TELL YOU THAT
THE DISCUSSION OF WITNESSES IS
PREMATURE.
WE DON'T KNOW THE SENATORS
ANYWAY.
WE DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS OF THE
PROSECUTION'S CASE.
IF WE DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DEFENSE
BECAUSE SPEAKER PELOSI DID NOT
ALLOW HIM TO HAVE ONE IN TERMS
OF THE PROSECUTION'S CASE.
NINE OUT OF 10 SENATORS, THEY
HAD BEEN READ THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE HOUSE.
ALL THEY HAD DONE IS LOOK AT THE
NEWS ARTICLES AND THEY ARE
READING THE MEDIA REPORTS.
AS WE KNOW AFTER THE REPORTING
ON THE STEELE DOSSIER, THEN WE
NEED TO HEAR THE PROSECUTION AND
THE DEFENSE.
I THINK THAT WILL TAKE PROBABLY
FOUR DAYS TOGETHER AND THEN THE
SENATORS CAN ASK QUESTIONS ON
THAT WILL TAKE A COUPLE DAYS.
I LEARNED A LOT FROM LISTENING
TO THE QUESTIONS AND LEARN A LOT
FROM LISTENING TO THE ANSWERS.
THAT MAY POSSIBLY BE WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND WE CAN MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT WITNESSES.
NOW I WANT TO BE FAIR ABOUT THE
WITNESSES.
WE TALK ABOUT CHUCK SCHUMER AS
WITNESSES OR SPEAKER PELOSI'S
WITNESSES -- I THINK THE
SPEAKERS AND SENATOR SCHUMER ARE
TOGETHER ON IT -- I WANT TO
TREAT THE DEFENSE FAIRLY.
EVERYBODY GETS A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD.
AND WE COULD END UP IN A VERY
ODD CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE
SENATOR SCHUMER, HE CAUGHT THE
CAR.
HE ASKED FOR HIS WITNESSES.
IN FAIRNESS, THE PRESIDENT GETS
HIS WITNESSES AND WE END UP
HEARING FROM HUNTER BIDEN AND
JOE BIDEN, WHOEVER ELSE IS ON
THE WITNESS LIST.
ANY OF THE CHAIRMAN THAT WERE
INVOLVED, AND THE PROSECUTION
DOESN'T GET TO HEAR ITS